what do you think of a burger what you
need is a great sauce and a light Smoky
Barbecue goes hand in glove with a great
burger
start by finely chopping one onion and
three cloves of garlic nice hot pan
tablespoon of olive oil onions and
garlic into the pan
salt and pepper a nice tablespoon brown
sugar a nice teaspoon of smoked paprika
onions and garlic beautifully
caramelized cider vinegar in reduce that
down in pre-made Worcester sauce and
tomato ketchup cut that out for two to
three minutes
take that out to give my mix a really
interesting flavor and texture I'm going
to be using unsmoked back bacon little
teaspoon of olive oil bacon in
schlots are a lot sweeter than your
normal white onion
fine fine fine and then
[Music]
now that Bacon's getting really nice and
crispy I want a bit of heat in the
little teaspoon
smoked paprika in there
and we see these Sliders in the states
for one portion there's like four or
five of them little mini
One Bites incredible now take your pork
just open up
and give that a really nice seasoning
so important you can't season a slider
after you've cooked it it's impossible
so season it nicely
bacon now that's nice and crispy
just take a little touch
ing rubble and just drain that off there
[Music]
nice
Pat that nice and dry I want all that
nice sort of crispiness
in there beautiful mix all that in take
a nice pour and sort of roll it
size of a golf ball
get it nice and round first and then
three fingers
Pat that down
don't flatten them too thin otherwise
they overcook and they go sort of dry
the slide is a bite-sized Burgers
designed to go in small buns you don't
want to make them too big
good
get the pan nice and hot tablespoon of
olive oil when a slider is literally
that thick about an inch thick we're
going to take two and a half to three
minutes each side in
turn them over
lovely
once you've turned them tilt the pan and
just spoon
all that juice back into them keep my
mouth watering now
so easy to dry the pork out so just
feeling it now with your fingers is nice
and firm it's a little touch of
springiness in the center I'm happy with
those
add your cheese now so it gets nicely
melted I'm using wedges or smoked
cheddar
and it has that nice sort of soury smoky
creaminess to the slider
finally shredded baby gem lettuce
take those buns make sure they're sliced
nice and evenly take your lettuce be
quite generous with the lettuce it's a
nice thin slice
tomato
take your burgers
see that cheese
if you know
female barbecue sauce
foreign
and that is my version the slider that
is small Dynamic but packed full of
flavor I'll take that over a hamburger
any day
a fantastically aromatic
melt-in-the-mouth treat pork neck curry
with mango salsa
[Music]
for the curry paste add chopped
lemongrass chili fresh ginger garlic and
caffeine Lime Leaf to a pestle and
mortar
next put an aromatic ground cinnamon and
coriander
pinch of salt black pepper
then bash it into a rough paste
finally add olive oil to loosen and your
paste is done now onto the pork neck add
a lug of olive oil to a hot pan and
brown the diced meat carefully
making sure each side hits the heat
locking in that flavor
remove and in the same pan cook sliced
onions until Brown around the edges
curry paste and Fry to release all the
intense flavors
then put the port back in along with the
coconut milk and stir
next add chicken stock palm sugar
more kaffir lime leaves soy sauce and
fish sauce to taste
then simply simmer for an hour
[Music]
slow cooked for succulents spicy super
easy to make and wonderful served with
fresh mango salsa pork neck Curry
slow roasted pork belly with fennel
[Music]
slow roasting works better on fattier
tougher and unfashionable cuts whether
it's a cheek or even a neck or this
amazing pork belly it's a fantastic way
to transform cheap cuts into amazing
melting perfection
take a very sharp knife bring the pork
belly towards you so you're over it
you've got all that pressure and weight
using the tip of the knife I'm just sort
of nicking it and go across the pork
belly long strokes with a knife take
your time turn it 180 this time what
we're doing is just sort of cutting
those nice little sort of diamonds but
as that starts roasting on top it starts
to get nice and crispy
take your handfuls of salt and just sort
of rub it in bend it over and then all
those cracks really helps to get a nice
crisp crackling on top
roasting tray
get it really nice and hot
take a hole over fennel to intensify
flavor and to keep the meat succulent
I'm braising my pork belly with strong
vibrant spices and vegetables crush and
peel three whole cloves of garlic and
add to the fennel olive oil in
fennel in
I like the nice strong aniseed flavor
that goes with that nice rich dense pork
fennel seeds delicious
Taiwanese in
and just a couple of cardamom seeds
and wow they're like little bangers like
little firecrackers incredible
lovely
fresh bay leaves
get your pork skin side down
just see her on top of that fat that
locks in all that amazing flavor then
I'm going to flip it over and get it
nice and crispy
and then on fennel seeds embedded in
those little cracks
now some white wine
the minute that white wine hits that pan
you can just smell that light fragrance
and the fennel
allow the wine to Bubble away and reduce
until the alcohol is burnt off time to
have the stock NOW the stock goes in
just underneath the skin so it roasts on
top all that meat under there could be
submerged because what happens in the
oven the top goes crispy as anything
and the stock reduces and braises at the
same time
really importantly bring that back up to
the ball before it goes in the oven
otherwise it will never boil never go up
to temperature
smells incredible
slow roasted pork belly at 180 degrees
for two and a half hours
[Music]
look at that you've got that nice crispy
skin on top
you can see how much of the stock has
evaporated
put that onto the board
it looks stunning
to make a delicious rustic sauce with
the flavor packed contents of the
roasting tray first get rid of the
excess fat take a couple of slices of
bread it's like a perfect sponge because
you just lay that
on top and drag it almost like a net and
it just absorbs all that fat if you want
the perfect fried bread trust me stick
that in a frying pan
a nice teaspoon of mustard whisk that in
and then simply simmer for a few minutes
before pouring into a serving jug
[Music]
with your pork belly always use a nice
serrated edge knife
can hear that
wow
my next dish throws a Spanish Twist on a
classic English roast pork stuffed with
Manchego and menbrillo
pork loin roasting joint
[Music]
lay the joints skin side down and cut
three quarters of the way into the flesh
creating space for the stuffing
next thinly sliced Spanish Manchego
cheese this has a wonderful buttery
nutty taste and it's fantastic for
stuffing as it melts brilliantly
sliced Spanish membrillo Queens jelly
sweet and perfumed is the perfect
partner for the saltiness of the cheese
then simply layer your cheese and Quince
jelly into the pork
Sage leaves for a strong and deliciously
bitter flavor
roll the meat up
[Music]
and tie with butcher's string
next add more Sage leaves and some
aromatic fresh thyme to a roasting tin
then lay the pork on top skin Side Up
cut a bulb of garlic in half and wedge
it under the meat the garlic wedges help
lift the pork so it roast to Perfection
and will add a sweet depth of flavor to
your gravy
drizzle with olive oil
season and roast for just over an hour
with the heat on high for the first 20
which helps get the skin crispy and
golden
once cooked leave the pork to rest as
you make a stunning gravy
simply Place The Roasting tin over a
medium Heat
add a lug of Sherry and delays using the
roasting juices gives your gravy maximum
flavor
simmer and reduce for a few minutes then
pour in incredible resting juices from
the pork
finally strain the silky Rich gravy over
the stuffed loin and serve immediately
through with Incredible flavor Rich
sweet and aromatic a stunning
centerpiece fit to Grace any table
anywhere anytime
[Music]